well CBS says former chairman and CEO
Leslie Moonves will not get the 120
million dollar severance payment his
contract called for the CBS Board of a
director said yesterday there are
grounds to terminate Moonves for cause
allowing the company to block that
payout board members made the decision
after reading the results of an
independent investigation into sexual
misconduct allegations against Moonves
and the overall culture at CBS Jericka
Duncan is here with the board's
description of that report Jericka good
morning good morning bianna to law firms
were investigating allegations against
Leslie Moonves to help the CBS Board
decide if it had the grounds to
terminate him without severance pay well
the board said yesterday investigators
found it did once a television Titan
Leslie Moonves is more than two decades
at CBS came to an end in September after
multiple women came forward accusing him
of sexual misconduct and retaliation on
Monday CBS moved to deny Moonves his 120
million dollar golden parachute saying
its outside investigation concluded he
violated company policies breached his
contract and failed to cooperate fully
with their investigation just last week
Moonves faced allegations from another
high-profile accuser he says well you
know why don't you let me take you home
I said no I've got a ride actress Cybill
Shepherd claimed her CBS show Sybil was
taken off the air in 1998 after she
rejected moonves's advances how soon
after that then did you find that you
were having issues with the series of
quite shortly after no kidding
mm-hmm unbelievable do you think back to
that day and wonder if things had had
gone differently what would have
happened to the show it would have run
another five years while CBS's full
report has not been released the New
York Times says it reviewed a leaked
draft in which investigators say they
found issues with CBS's anti harassment
and other policies they found Moonves
and about 30 other senior leaders were
typically allowed to sidestep anti
harassment training and some senior
people in the news division historically
had their assistants complete the
training for them over the past year CBS
News has
scrutiny it fired 60 minutes executive
producer Jeff Fager
for sending a threatening message to
this reporter and it fired CBS this
morning co-host Charlie Rose over sexual
misconduct allegations but the CBS board
said Monday investigators concluded
harassment and retaliation are not
pervasive at the company we asked 16
employees here at the CBS News division
about that conclusion one employee told
us they agree with the Board's
assessment but another employee said a
culture of harassment is being
overlooked here a different employee
told us they feel secrecy allowed the
problems at CBS to fester for decades
and without transparency this process
has zero credibility they must release
the investigators report CBS declined to
answer additional questions when we
reached out including whether it plans
to release the report the company did
say it has begun to take robust steps to
improve the working environment for all
employees
an attorney for Moonves said in a
statement the conclusions of the CBS
board were for ordained and are without
merit
adding Moonves vehemently denies any
non-consensual sexual relations and
cooperated extensively and fully with
investigators
Moonves has also previously denied
retaliating against women it is unclear
right now if Moonves will fight the
decision on his pay John all right
tarika thank you well it's clear that
the reckoning continues and you can't
you can't provide solutions until you
know fully what the problem is and what
exists and so that secrecy that still
exists the people that have covered up
that behavior that still needs to be
clarified until we can make the
meaningful changes and I do believe that
those on the board there are now six
women on the board there are five men it
is a majority female board that they are
pushing for change and the Board says
they want transparency and they want to
do the right thing I've also from the
camp of we have to see what's in the
report so we know exactly what we're
dealing with and now you can change it
and how you can get rid of the people
that no longer need to be here who are
still involved in whatever this behavior
is I do think it's a brand new day let's
say I hope it's a brand new I think we
have to wait to the new year
you have been promised that a new day is
on the horizon and we are holding firm
the idea
yes day in the new year